so i have two good friends that are
trial lawyers in florida they they they
they represent they're public defenders
and uh
yeah and i said uh because you're
representing good people now they're in
down in miami and i said county i said
hey and he goes it's just been very
tough and i go why because with covetous
people are going crazy i said
so what do you mean a lot of kidnappings
there's going there's a lot of
kidnapping going on and a lot of uh a
lot of that that happens that ends
very badly [ __ ] yeah and they deal with
that [ __ ] and of course i'm so morbid
i'm like tell me more oh yeah i want the
details even if it bothers me i want the
details but it'll [ __ ] your day up man
yeah and you know what i do because i'm
a civilian i go but but usually they
they it doesn't end in death and they go
oh it ends in terrible sexual crimes and
death and i'm like oh okay and they have
to they have to defend those people but
don't you think and you don't do me
around nobody loves cops more than i do
but don't you think those cops have a
skewed view on
yeah
it's like what's his name who survived
the world world war ii
and they said um he they said the guy
who wrote where the wild things are and
they said
yeah and they said um
are you do you believe in god and he
said no he just really casually goes no
no the war took care of that for me oh
wow just like that yeah once you see
some [ __ ] yeah it's it's like no no
whatever god you believe
my house got broken new years ago
and i was i was yelling at the cops
because i was i came in late and i'm
like where the [ __ ] were you guys it
took you 14 minutes man and he goes you
know how big l.a county is dude we don't
have enough cops he goes i tell every
and i talked to the same cops about this
today he's like you got to be able to
fight for around eight to ten minutes
your life is online for about eight ten
so you gotta be able to fight so these
people who live these cush lifestyles
and you know don't train or work out
like yourself he's like you'll be able
to fight for about eight ten minutes
before he can get there he's like
because you can't fight you're [ __ ]
well i also say and he's like not and he
was in i he goes you know i wouldn't go
on record saying i tell everyone carry a
gun of course he's even if you don't
have a concealed weapon license care
again we can't search your car if we
don't have a reason to so you might as
well carry one have a gun have a [ __ ]
[ __ ] boys it's true yeah
i would rather have a gun by the way
when you say fight back that's what
you're talking about because they i
assume that guy has a gun you're coming
into my house and i'm gonna i'm gonna
[ __ ] i i i assume you're here to kill
me well i was telling the cop i was like
yeah these guys brought my house and uh
and i said yeah and they had guns of
course who's gonna break into your house
without guns he was if he goes if he was
let's say three of them broken they have
guns you'd strangle the [ __ ] out of them
because nobody's bringing your house
without a gun dude so you should
automatically assume every time they
come in there if they do again they have
a gun yes because you have guns i go do
i ever dude and also you want a tactical
shotgun with some bird shot in it
that yeah move on you want to be ready
for that here's the problem the ar-15
too loud simply too loud they're too
loud and they will blow out everybody's
ear drums so [ __ ] cops beg to differ i
want a shotgun i'll get a tactical shot
cups that have all of it
yeah we'll have the zombie apocalypse
you got to be ready for everything yeah
i'm not storing enough food
you know tim kennedy is the guy who's
got like you know he's too far away
five elk that are frozen and freezing
okay he's ready to go and you really get
cash those are the guys i don't know
they're far away though yeah
yeah i get donald let's go i need to get
a [ __ ] texas man
well now texas has its own problems
texas got worse
water problems and things like that but
i agree do you weigh the pros and cons
yeah it's just i love i love california
man i'll stay here i'm gonna i'm gonna
gut i'm gonna die here i'm gonna cut it
out
it would have to get exceptionally bad
for me to i mean like now shitty but i'm
an optimist and i think things you know
they things ebb and flow me too i think
once news comes out you somebody in
there knows what the [ __ ] they're doing
yeah
i think once 2024 comes around things
bounce back a little bit well you just
you know again it goes back to are the
bad ideas going to win or are the good
ideas going to win that's the problem so
you know right now i think a lot of bad
ideas are winning